hello and welcome back to matt's tech
parade today we're going to be looking
at davinci resolve i know a lot of
people that watch my channel use blender
for video editing because i have a
series on it and it's pretty much the
most popular videos on my channel
however davinci resolve is actually made
for making videos okay so we're gonna
launch it i'm gonna walk you through
basically all the processes i typically
use this is not an all-inclusive
tutorial because well first of all i'm
not going through the install so you
gotta handle that yourself but it's
pretty straightforward download unpack
install you'll get this it'll be blank
at first this is just stuff i've worked
on in the past a lot of random stuff
let's go over the stuff here we've got a
slider bar
we got this list view
and there's this special information
which gives you more data
a little sort order and if you're
connecting to a database somewhere we'll
be pressing these buttons over here
collapse that back down we're just going
to do a new project so we click on this
untitled project or you can go to new
project down here you can also make
folders and we're just going to do a new
project let's press this new project
button we'll leave it as it is untitled
project one as we can see eventually
does let us know when there's a new
version 17.3 is available so i'm going
to pause the video and go grab
17.3 and i'll be right back excellent
excellent the only thing you really need
to know about the setup is i left
everything default so everything is just
just where default would go
right so we've got the new version
installed and we're going to launch it
is this little what's new in davinci
resolve so uh that's kind of cool
they're always fixing stuff excellent
now we're back to the normal startup and
here we are back at a project we're just
going to open project one because that's
the one we already started and here we
have a blank interface so in this
default interface well there's a lot of
stuff going on let's go over quickly of
course you've got a standard menu bar at
the top that you see on pretty much
every piece of software these days and
then we got this little strip bar here
that basically changes this top left
area you can see there's media pool for
importing things sync ben which i've
never used transitions and
transitions too so additional
tabs here for more stuff titles and it
looks like we can favorite them with the
star
effects and we have all kinds of effects
here
and down here we have our timeline and
cutting area this is controlled by this
down here right now we're on cut there's
also edit which goes into a whole new
mode the larger sidebar here
and it has some different options on the
the cutting so these are sort of similar
i've noticed the cut and edit cut is uh
more intended for slicing up your clip
only
edits more for adding things in but you
there's no reason you can't add stuff in
during the cut so i don't it's sort of
an odd thing to me but it's that's just
the way it is i switch between them as
needed typically fusion allows you to
make custom properties on things it's a
little more advanced we might talk about
it more later but today it's not really
too relevant for the basics color is
basically for color grading your clips a
cool tool to have available fair light
is all about controlling your audio and
doing stuff with audio this is also
something we'll look at occasionally too
but probably not today as the basics
will be handled mostly in the importing
and basic cutting and how to render a
video and i will do follow-ups to cover
the rest of the stuff okay so the first
thing we want to do now that we're used
to the interface a little bit is bring
in some media that we would like to edit
you can edit pretty much anything you
want audio video
and images go to your file explorer go
find some stuff i've got a place on one
of my drives for recordings rendered and
a bunch of other stuff created images
created sounds and stuff that's open you
can organize however you want i'm just
going to go into my recordings so we're
going to drag this in and right away it
asks us if we want to change the project
frame rate it tries to match what you're
recording at so it does try to help you
out with that so you can bring in
everything you want to work with it's
the point here i'm just dragging on
random clips if you only have one that's
fine too let's bring in some images to
play around with to bring in audio
here's a bunch i'll just drag them all
in and the reality is you don't actually
need to use this import like ever
because while you're working in your
timeline you can just drag stuff in as
you need it
so when you drag something into this
working area it creates a very special
media pool entry called timeline and
this timeline
is what you actually edit
so in the cut phase you basically hit
control slash or right click and go to
split anywhere you want
control
backslash the slash above enter does it
cut and s and spacebar plays there's a
obviously very loud audio there so i'm
gonna actually mute the audio so we're
gonna go over here to uh audio well
there's some master audio that we can
actually edit so if we go over to edit
we'll see in our mixer over here we have
audio one and the bus if you turn the
bus all the way down that's going to
turn off your sound entirely you turn
audio one down that's going to turn off
the audio on audio one you can also hit
mute track over here so when you're in
this cut mode and you click on something
that you've sliced around and press the
backspace key it will remove it and
bring back your
timeline to match
so if we want to just cut say the
beginning we can make a cut over here
control slash press the back base key
and there we go
and then you can uh hit this fast review
to zoom on through at a higher speed
than normal which is doing it doesn't
seem a whole lot faster there it goes
not speeding up
and you can hit it again now wait till
you get to like an exciting part or
whatever if you don't want to go to your
mouse and have to click these uh areas
you can hold control to press the left
and right arrow keys and it will change
what is selected i guess you have to
click one to start but then you can
highlight the one you want so you can
work with all your keyboard once you get
used to the hotkeys and you can fly
through this using only your keyboard so
it might be a good idea at this point to
study the hotkeys do some cuts go over
to edit after doing some cuts and go to
your media pool drag in some other stuff
play around with these
because audio goes down below video goes
up above you'll get scroll bars over
here once you've gotta get a bunch of
stuff going on a bunch of layers uh
player play around with the effects
library and the titles
and the transitions you just drag
transitions right onto any cut area
titles it just gives you a bunch of
different text some of these are going
to be paywall maybe especially once you
get to effects a lot of these are
paywall and you'll get this message
saying you need to buy davinci so when
you're using this in this free version
you don't get all their special designed
effects but you still do get all the
core stuff you need to edit videos and
as you can see at this point there's a
lot of stuff here
but i've kind of tried to go over where
to find the basics it's definitely not
everything there's definitely a ton of
stuff i didn't go over but at this point
you should feel pretty comfortable uh
clicking around on your own and doing
some basic cuts so
we're going to hop right on a little
further let me let me just layer a few
things real quick let's put in some
scroll text at the beginning now you'll
see it's scroll title you have to go to
the inspector and the inspector is
specifications or details on whatever
you're currently editing so
if you click something it'll switch to
that you do have to click it for the
inspector to be correct so watch out for
that sometimes you'll drag something in
start editing and then realize oh i'm
editing the wrong thing we change the
scroll title just i don't know whatever
you want and there's
all kinds of formatting options
drop shadow background stuff you could
play around with
whatever you want to do here do some
random random things
and then maybe we'll make a few more
cuts this area looks a little bit quiet
let's cut it so you can do the same
cut effects while you're in edit but
when you press the backspace button well
you do need to make sure you select the
audio with it both the audio and the
video and then have some more things
here like snapping and link sections
that links the audio the video so if you
want to make sure you select both
you keep it linked if you want to split
you can unlink and then you can edit one
of the other careful timing you can mess
up your timing but maybe you don't need
the audio because you're just using it
as like a
something else you decide but hitting
backspace leaves this space this gap
here so i'm going to hit ctrl z to undo
that but hitting the delete key you know
the one that's next to insert an end on
your keyboard that delete key will pull
things back now you can also if you
hover over you'll see you get this
little special side rail thing at that
point you can click and drag
and you can do it on any of these clips
it does have snapping unless you unsnap
by pressing in or toggling this little
area there's also some stuff over here
you can play around with i use this one
the blade mode which basically just
makes cuts wherever you click slice it
up with the blade mode so you can then
go back to your cursor selection mode
with a and click on maybe one section
that you don't actually want and
we'd go back to blade mode this is just
another way of cutting a select delete
blade cut cut cut cut select day oh and
now i've hit the end key accidentally so
the end key takes you to the end you
want to go back to where you were
press uh i don't know good luck i guess
you just need to zoom out with this and
go back to where you were basically so
i want to select and delete just
deleting the assignment parts with the
uh pullback thing
i i can't remember what that's called
where it uh
goes back all right i'm just going to
make a few more cuts here where it keeps
the clip aligned without the blank space
so if i press the backspace key it
doesn't do that you see all right so
backspace doesn't and you don't always
want it to do that because maybe you
have something else going on
that's real quick but if you have all
these gaps it can be a real pain to go
in and be like uh snap that one over
that one oops now they've combined
together so that could be real pain but
what you can do is you click somewhere
where you have nothing selected so click
this blank area make sure there's
nothing in your inspector go up to edit
and then delete gaps and this will
delete all the gaps i'm going to hit
undo and show you what happens if you do
have something selected say i have this
selected and now i go to delete gaps
does nothing does absolutely nothing
so that's why you have to select nothing
uh because if you have something
selected i think it only deletes the
gaps in that clip let's do a test i
think maybe if we go like this and then
hit delete gaps maybe it'll get rid of
the ones yeah the ones within the
selection so you either have to select
everything or select nothing or only
select the area you want to delete gaps
from
and this box select of course just click
and drag
so that's another way to clear up your
gaps if you have not been pressing the
delete key all the time maybe you're
only doing backspace some of the time
like so and then you want to like clear
that up later there we go
so maybe we want a little outro or
something or something some effects
within here
so what you can do
is
you just click on one of these clips
right
and now we go up to effects library
and there's all kinds of stuff in here
you can put effects over from over here
and drag on adjustment clip fusion
composition you can
put any of these titles with it if you
want so now this clip here this is kind
of a long clip let me do a shorter one
so you can drag stuff all over the top
of it like that and do whatever you want
but you can also edit these clips
directly there's some there's several
ways of doing this so you select it and
you can go over here to this drop down
and there's crop zoom overlay fusion uh
the the transform is very commonly used
that's the one that just does a hard
zoom
rotate
so you can do whatever you want there
let's do that so that section will just
go boom sideways it's kind of a weird
effect and if we want to drop in any of
these fades at any time we can
our transitions there's all these video
transitions that automate things there's
quite a few of them let's do a slice
push on this one so another thing you
can do is with this double hover you'll
see you got the bars on the both sides
of the arrows on both sides and you can
click it and move where this cut is so
maybe you want to find just that and do
that
so that is another really little handy
tip it's just to get that double hover
and fine adjust where your cuts are
if you
that's
want
thing of beauty sometimes so i'm just
randomly editing here clearly uh
normally when you're editing you're
probably going to go through this
meticulously and and do
things as you want so on any of these
clips you can also do a manual fade in
and fade out by just clicking on these
little
i don't know nodes on the end of a clip
and just pulling it and that controls a
fade so if we bring our playhead here
see that this is going to fade out
and usually you want to adjust
accordingly so that we could do like a
fade out and a fade into the next clip
type of thing
all right so let's get to the important
part of
delivering your product all right we've
gotten this far maybe we're ready to
deliver there might be more stuff you
want to do let me know down below we'll
make some follow-up videos i'm just
going to go ahead and hit deliver
and this is the all-important render
area what you can do here is you can
mark in and mark out now this is where
your video starts and where your video
ends so that can be important sometimes
you'll say like the this intro thing is
really not good let me just start right
here so or maybe i just want to render a
small section to show somebody maybe
it's like hey guys [ __ ] check this out
what do you think of this part mark
again mark out
and then you can just render that
section so that's how you control which
section is rendering uh but let's go
back to entire timeline so you got all
these options up here this is where you
set up how you want to export there's so
many options from audio only pro tools
generic twitter
to youtube if you're going to youtube
you click youtube gives you the default
options go on vimeo click that you know
you can probably find a good option for
yourself here
for what is going to work for you so
let's go to youtube
and give it a file name give it a
location i'm going to choose my render
folder
rendered
save give it a file name i'm just going
to asdf this one and you probably want
to keep this resolution and frame rate
and all this stuff as it is now you can
log in and like have the stuff auto
upload to youtube i don't do that i just
manually do that later but then all you
do is you click add to render queue and
then render all over here so this is
your render key so you can actually set
up multiple things to render you can say
like it's uh
let's set this one up add that one so
you can have like little multiple mini
pieces if you want and render them all
so if we click render all it's actually
going to start rendering and it tells
you how long which can very greatly i'm
going to stop it but basically you're
going to find it in whatever folder you
specified here once it's all done
and that's pretty much it all right
thanks for watching hopefully uh this
helps you get started with davinci
resolve 17.3 my name is matt
i've been watching uh matt's crab shack
of code and technology and stuff you
want to support for whether there is a
patron down below and stuff so uh yeah
i guess i'll see you guys in the next
one leave comments let me know what i uh
should show next because there's there's
a lot of stuff i was feeling like maybe
i should talk more about audio or about
importing these pictures
we can do that next time
i'll see you guys in that next time area
you